the Pentagon losing one of America's
most sophisticated weapons like it was a
set of car keys for 28 hours our
nation's top brass couldn't seem to find
an $80 million F-35 fighter jet that
went missing its pilot forced to eject
himself from the cockpit over some
unknown issue and the jet coasted on
autopilot with a transponder shut off
again for some unknown reason the search
got so desperate the general public was
asked to help located and the Marine
Corps had to ground all Jets eventually
they found the wreckage in South Carol
Carolina estate Dana some 80 miles from
where it took off not surprising the
Biden Administration doesn't have any
answers how does the United States lose
track of a 80 90 million doll F35
pentagon's you know just before coming
on to see you I I I called my colleagues
at the defense department to check in on
that and they are investigating this
entire mishap as you would anyway and
certainly they'll take a look at the
search and Recovery efforts of the airc
craft and um and how they found it and
whether or not processes could have been
different when this is over uh there
will be a complete transparent
comprehensive investigation and you can
count on the defense department to come
public with what they've
learned and one of our lesser talents at
Fox spoke to a former fighter pilot on
what may have
happened if it's a stealth fighter then
it's a stealth fighter we're not going
to see that airplane so um if the if the
pilot ejected as wingman or his flight
lead is supposed to do rest cap uh over
the air area where the pilot ejected and
then if the F-35 was in fact on
autopilot or maybe even not on autopilot
but under power the airplane's going to
trim itself for one g or the autopilots
going to take over it looks like if the
debris field is really the jet it flew
for another 80 miles which uh it could
easily
do wow he does look like a pilot uh
Harold in The Green Room you said this
is yet another Insurrection clearly
Trump supporters had built the plane and
the pilot was a Democrat
protester I'm writing all this I want to
check the tape to make sure I don't
recall that when I but I'll tell you
this this is a I'm not going to
speculate a whole lot um I did when I
saw the story earlier uh and listened to
to to that fella on your show Jess it
made me think a couple things one this
was not the first time this has happened
I think in in the last in the last few
months two um could this be some sort of
hack could this be some sort of
infiltration from from someone outside
of the United States when you think of
all the things that have happened just
in the last week from uh the Las Vegas
hotels and casinos being hacked to
obviously uh a whole range of companies
that impact our lives uh and with what
we've known over the last several years
and particularly in the last year where
we saw this balloon go over the United
States uh is there some foreign foreign
infiltration here some foreign hacking
here I trust uh Mr Kirby is right and
our military has every right and we'll
have every incentive to get to the
bottom of it and I would imagine they
even working with the the manufacturer
of that that steal yet as well so I'll
wait for the facts to come out M AI
Herold all
right Dana in The Green Room you said
obviously they're not talking about this
cuz the pilot a female I thought that
was so sexist explain your theories I
mean I can't believe it it's really
outrageous um and the story is quite
wild right so it's about aund million
dollar really all told if you to talk
about it and we're just losing them and
so I'm very Pro defense spending but
it's not a great look when you are about
to have a big spending fight in Congress
and you want more money for defense and
you're just losing things that you could
have put an Apple Air tag on and you're
asking the neighborhood watch program to
help you figure out if you can do this
the interesting thing is about the hack
the fact that it was lost means our
stealth technology works but on Saturday
in the Wall Street Journal there was a
front page story it was very disturbing
about how China and Russia have
leapfrogged us in terms of hypersonic
missiles so we are behind in the
technology and we need to get ahead and
this might not be the way to do it Apple
Air tags for planes that's an
interesting idea it seems pretty easy I
have one on my dog all right judge uh
you're always supposed to really eject
yourself when the other choice is death
do you think maybe it's an embarrassing
error because they he shouldn't have
ejected or
she or they I don't have the slightest
idea because if Pentagon doesn't know
pmo couldn't couldn't assess what was
going on and I talked to Kirby before he
went on with Martha and he said we
really don't know you know what's crazy
about this I mean if he ejects he made
the decision to eject right I mean
should the plane just drop down at that
point or you know how far does it go you
know what if it were over a city or a
hospital or a school I mean is it that
dangerous and Dana you make a great
point I mean I have air tags on my dogs
I know where they are at any moment that
we could lose something like this and
apparently it's what's called a Class A
mishap when something is worth 2 and a
half million everybody goes into you
know we got to find this thing mode and
they couldn't find it they it was like
Crim Stoppers they had to ask the public
do have you seen an F35 in in the area I
mean think about how crazy that is and
you know but it's like typical for this
Administration right they lost 85
migrant kids and $80 billion in military
equipment in Afghanistan we lost the
service members there they lost cocaine
at the White House and one purpose and
one person in the white house actually
lost his m
yeah there you
goess tag for that Jesse in The Green
Room you said to me obviously it's a
male pilot cuz when they found the plane
it was nicely parked between the
lines I came out and looked at Emma's
car the other day and there was a little
dent in it and I said what's this dent
and she said oh oh that oh and then she
had an explanation but you know what she
was contrite mhm all we're asking for is
a little contrition that was a couple
hundred on her car this is $100 million
we paid for that and talk about the six
billion they lost in Afghanistan all the
money they they leave in Ukraine no
one's saying you know what taxpayers we
apologize this is a $1.7 trillion joint
fighter program over the course of the
program and they're so
expensive they're like Lamborghinis we
don't even really use them and I read
that they can take off and land
vertically and they hover yeah think
about that but we're so like you at a
bar I'm just G to go a commercial now no
go
ahead what else do you want from me
Greg you want to know what it's like to
eject you know the handsome pilot you
know what he told me he's like it's
going from 5 G's into 300 knot wind my
God Called It traumatic wow I said I
wanted an ejector seed on the five yeah
for who that guy I think we can agree
that this is grounds for impeachment so
absolutely we'll be uh touching that
later hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now